everybody keeps hitting me up about a
wedding crashers sequel we don't have a
script that were there with yet for many
many years every year I got offered to
do the sequel there were some very big
deals on the table and none of us really
wanted to do a retread of the same movie
again you know we didn't want an
anything within those first years that
we talked about was the same movie and
we were like why you know financially I
probably should have done that but that
but that is I did and not in Vincent
Owen didn't want to do it either but ten
years later when I was asked again and I
hung up the phone after saying no I
thought about it and I'm like well I'd
be curious would it be like four guys in
their late 40s who end up being single
again and have to go back out into the
world like what a weird difficult
challenging story that is and as long as
there's a real story in the middle of it
to me it can be a movie you know every
one of my films I try to have something
that explores something that the
characters are going through that I'm
trying to work out myself where I think
the audience is try to work out and so
we'll see so we started noodling on it a
while ago and we're unclear yet you know
Vince has to read it and Owen has to
read it I saw something that seemed like
a good start but there's no rush to go
make that movie and I'm not sure what's
next you know I always I see a lot of
comedies comedies in a very interesting
place right now I was really happy to be
back in it and do it again
it is my fastball and I do love the
experience of it and you know we'll see
how this comes out for Netflix you know
I hope it does well and it's certainly a
movie that I think people will discover
is really entertaining and really a
relief from everything that's going on
right now
100% well one of the things and I know I
know I got a rap but one of the things
about a wedding crasher sequel now
versus doing it twelve years ago is that
you can use what a lot of sequels are
doing now which is you're using real
to allow the characters to now have aged
exactly and and that make that is a way
more compelling sequel than just doing
it three years later repeating
absolutely look at Blade Runner look I
love Blade Runner the the 24th 2014 eine
is that the date 20 49 is amazing I love
that movie and I love that Harrison is
in it he's not in it as a cameo he's
really in the movie and it means
something and it answers things that
I've been wondering about I mean I
thought that movie was tremendous and it
couldn't have happened it should never
have happened until then so that was one
of those movies that really struck me as
well I agree with what you're saying man
I think that's totally right like tell a
new story that's the whole thing like
don't do the same thing again
there are many comedies that I like the
sequels to again Austin Powers I thought
the sequel was the second movie was
better than the first but you know we
grew up with jaws too and like sequels
were shitty for a long time unless it
was a series like James Bond it was
really sequels were joke a bit of a joke
and when it first came out and there was
one afternoon when Owen and Vince and I
sat around and talked about it and you
could feel like even if we were laughing
at it we were coming up with hilarious
[ __ ] it really was us kind of riffing
what we've done and we just looked at
each other and we're like let's not do
it you know I don't there's no need to
you know but I I will tell you that like
the idea of don't getting being able to
see those two guys and get together and
do that again would be a thrill you know
I'm a fan of them